Let's do a quick comparison of switches and routers.
Switches typically operate at layer two. A common protocol at
layer two is ethernet. Switches are typically automatically configuring
and forwarding tends to be quite fast, since packets only
need to be processed through layer two on flat
look ups. Routers, on the other hand, typically operate at
layer three where IP is the common protocol. And
router level topologies are not restricted to a spanning tree.
One can even have multipath routing, where a
single packet could be sent along one of
multiple possible paths in the underlying router level
topology. So, in many ways ethernet, or layer two
switching, is a lot more convenient, but one
of the major limitations is broadcast. The spanning
tree protocol messages and ARP queries both impose
a fairly high load on the network. So this
raises the question of whether it's possible to
get many of the benefits of the auto configuration
and fast forwarding of layer two without facing
these broadcast limitations. As it turns out, there are
ways to strike this balance. And in the
third part of the course, when we talk about
network management, we will look at some ways
to scale Ethernet to very large topologies. For example,
in data center networks. We'll also explore
how an emerging technology called Software Define
Networking, or SDN, is effectively blurring the
boundary between the layer two and layer three.